on a le met d'abord Florent le bilan ne
cesse de s'alourdir au Maroc on est à
plus de 2500 morts ce soir 2500 morts et
autant de blessés mais aussi et des
milliers de personnes sans toi pour leur
venir en aide plusieurs collectivités en
premier une aide financière comme le
Conseil départemental d'Indre-et-Loire
mais aussi la région Centre-Val de Loire
avec un chèque de 200000 € à jouer les
tours l'association franco-marocaine
elle est à l'écoute des tours en jouant
inquiets centralise les dons qui
affluent par centaines Lucas Chopin
merci infiniment madame merci
à très vite à très vite madame au revoir
le téléphone ne cesse de sonner au siège
de l'association France Maroc ça
n'arrête pas et on a une vraiment
une forte solidarité
dirais-je en Indre-et-Loire mais aussi
sur sur la région et sur les chaînes
nationales
cette association basée à jouer les
tours jouit d'excellentes relations avec
les autorités françaises et marocaines
depuis samedi matin ses membres se
relaient nuit et jour pour répondre aux
milliers d'appels de soutien et aux
propositions de dons un français et le
Maroc elles sont je dirais pas des pays
amis gérer beaucoup plus loin dans mon
propos
je dirais plus des pays frères en tant
que président de la communauté France
Maroc de voir ce geste ces gestes de
bonté je tenais vraiment insister
là-dessus et on voit qu'en France
vraiment il y a un grand élan de
solidarité d'humanisme ici tout est de
la bienvenue argent matériel de santé
produit d’hygiène et de première
nécessité mais France - Maroc représente
également un important soutien moral
pour les populations faut le vivre pour
le croire c'est c'est croyable moi je
sais qu'à 2h du matin mes parents je les
avais au téléphone j'entendais l'écrit
les bouleversants voyez-vous et
mets-nous notre rôle à nous aussi c'est
de garder la tête froide les gens nous
appellent en état de détresse et on est
là pour les rassurer pour répondre à
leurs doléances et leurs questions et
les mettre en lien avec leur famille on
avait des Marocains de Tours d'un peu
partout qui nous appelait parce qu'ils
avaient n'arrivaient pas à joindre leur
famille au Maroc toute proposition de
dons peut-être adressée par mail ou par
téléphone à l'association un RIB a même
été créé pour recevoir et transmettre
directement l'argent au pays un premier
camion de matériel partira cette nuit
pour le Maroc d'autres suivront les
jours à venir